congress is taking a major step to
combat hate crimes against
asian americans the senate
overwhelmingly passed a bill to expand
the federal government's role
this follows a recent surge in violence
related to the covet 19 pandemic
particularly against the asian american
community
congressional correspondent nicole
killian joins us now from capitol hill
nicole
it's pretty rare to see lawmakers come
together like this
what would this legislation actually do
absolutely michelle this bill was a
bipartisan effort and the lawmakers who
spearheaded this
hope it sent a powerful message not only
to the asian-american pacific islander
community
but to all americans the measure cleared
the senate
94-1 the lone no vote was missouri
republican josh hawley who felt it was
too broad
the coven 19 hate crimes act would
designate a point person at the
department of justice
to expedite the review of covet-19
related hate crimes it also provides
more guidance to state and local law
enforcement agencies to make it easier
to report hate crime incidents
and it expands public awareness
campaigns the legislation comes
just over one month after several women
of asian descent were killed in a mass
shooting in atlanta
from the start of the pandemic about 3
800
anti-asian crimes have been reported
president biden applauded the senate
action in a tweet writing acts of hate
against asian americans are wrong
un-american and must stop the bill now
heads to the house
for a final vote next month vlad
nicole thanks very much